العديد من القرارات التحكيميه المثيره
للجدل في المونديال نستعرض بعضها مدرب
منتخب غانا وصف ركله جزاء التي سجلها
رونالدو في مرمى فريقه بانها هديه خاصه من
الحكم وقرار خاطئ كلف فريقه المباراه اما
لاعب منتخب اوروغواي فاحتاجه على حكم
لقائهم امام غانا لانهم اعتقدوا انه حرمهم
الركلتي الجزاء واضاع عليهم فرصه تاهل
لدور ال16 هدف اليابان المثير للجدل امام
اسبانيا اعتقد الجمهور ان الكره تجاوزت خط
المرمى في تمريره قبل الهدف لكن الحقيقه
انها لم تخرج بكامل المحيطها لفريق
اسرائيل ربما سنتيمتر واحد او اقل بعد
لقاء المغرب في ربع النهائي اتهمت في
مدافع البرتغال الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
بالمحابات الارجنتين وترتيب اللقب من اجل
ميسي بسبب تعيين حكم الارجنتيني واعترض
على ايقافته المباراه كثيرا وعدم احتسابه
وقتا بدل ضائع كافي
والابرز انتقاد ميسي لحكم مباراه هولندا
والارجنتين الذي عاتب الفيفا وقال ان
عليهم مراجعه اختياراتهم للحكام في كاس
العالم